the groundbreaking TV show transparent
is expanding our understanding of gender
identity Jill Soloway is a show's Emmy
and Golden Globe winning creator in the
new memoir she wants it desire power and
toppling the patriarchy solloway shares
her journey to identifying as non-binary
now that means referring to oneself as
neither woman nor man and using the
pronoun day instead of she or he Sol
away also describes the impact of their
father coming out as transgender woman
which is also the basis of transparent
Jill Soloway joins us at the table hey
Jill Soloway yeah so I have to confess
here the first non-binary person that
we've had at the table that we know
about so I think we should take it so I
think a lot of people need an education
myself included because you were born
you called yourself in the book of
straight being a heterosexual straight
via a heterosexual woman yes and during
the course of your father's coming out
fathers strand generation you started
realizing things about yourself so what
does this mean exactly non-binary yeah
thanks for asking it is a very new thing
and it's part of the trans spectrum so
the word trans means bridge and a lot of
people are familiar with people who go
from one to the other assigned male at
birth transition and identify as female
but there are some people who stay on
the bridge and who are I described to
people as I'm sort of male sort of
female sort of both sort of neither
constantly changing and I like to say
she is fine when people say she and her
I don't correct them but when people say
they in them it's like frosting it's
like just an extra oh wow I feel seen
which is that would which would mean
that you guys all see me is not
necessarily a woman not necessarily a
man but I mean I stumbled and bumbled
leading to their memoir because I went
yeah for a memoir what's wrong with
saying her he/she what why is that no
longer there are some people like that
you know that the the word she describes
somebody who is female or sometimes
somebody who is fam or a female
presenting there's certain expectations
around she that don't necessarily feel
resonant with me yeah and same with he
some people don't really necessarily
feel that he describes them it's it's
it's more or less a third gender so the
book is called she wants this it's not
referring to you then who is this
referring to thank you for asking that
yeah it is a little bit referring to me
but
um I have been ashy my whole life and
the book is about desire so when I was
in my early 20s I wrote a documentary
proposal called she wants it and I was
really thinking about these things like
consent and gender this very question
we're asking right now which is are
women less trusted when it comes to
consent than men does being female or
femme or feminine put you at a
disadvantage to be trusted when you're
talking about whether or not you
consented and you know when you become a
director it's all about desire wanting
wanting wanting I want this camera I
want this set I want these actors but
the phrase she wants it is a phrase that
one man might say to another to insult a
woman mm-hmm she wants it or she wanted
it means she deserved what she got it's
an interesting journey for you because
you're doing this show and sometimes
you're wondering is it fiction or
reality because in some way you're
writing about a character yes you're
also writing about your own life yes I
feel very lucky that I get to use my
television making as art as a way to
process my own reality and do you have
people who respond and say thank God
because she gets it she I am understood
or do you have people to say huh
I mostly get people to say thank God you
know that you're saying these things and
doing these things because it allows me
to see versions of myself that are
possible and people feel seen I love
that exam yeah yeah right that you wrote
transparent to try and hurry up and
change the world yeah yeah when my
parent came out it was a different world
it was about five years ago and I
remember thinking if I can write
something quickly enough where my parent
can feel safe in the world even as
simple as getting in the elevator with
other people or getting into a taxi cab
and feeling like people might meet my
parent and say oh I've seen transparent
I understand there's a groundbreaking
program and yet so many people still
have so many on an answer class about it
do you have people asking you questions
all the time I think a very simple thing
is like the binary is not that
dependable in all ways you know good
girl bad girl victim villain man woman
there's stuff in between the binary that
I think is gonna help us get through
this next these next phase of humanity
it's interesting too that you're with
Amazon because so many networks didn't
want to touch it you and you went from
Amazon the shopping place where I buy my
banana slicer i order my chargers
Amazon took this on yes because they
clearly saw something that other people
did not see yes yeah and I'm really
grateful that they did yeah it's it's
it's an amazing place for innovation I
remember actually being here with Jeff
Bezos yes you guys a few years ago and
really feeling like wow that you know
that to be able to put television and
content together with you know the kind
of services they providing the stuff
they sell is kind of a new thing big
changes at the show because the star
Jeffrey Tambor yes has now left the show
as to leave the show because of
allegations associated with the me2
movement how do you pivot when that was
the whole show was basically based on
their coming out yeah well that's why
we're you know hoping that people will
tune in for our fifth and final season
which is actually gonna be a movie
musical so we're we're pivoting in a way
that I think is helping the show
transition in people's minds just
something that can be joyful and you
know exploratory and fun and bring bring
the joy all right we should say that
Jeffery denies the charges that's
important to say it Jill thank you
because I have so many questions I'm
really glad that we could ask ask them
and you not think stupid with two O's
because I think a lot of people are very
I'm really happy to be that person who
helps people ask questions yeah seeing
you know it's all I want to bring some
fun to the conversation thank you for
doing that yeah Jill Soloway she wants
it goes on sale tomorrow